The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHAEL SHORT: I got
an interesting question
in the anonymous
comment box, and I
want to see how many
other people agree
with it the comment
when something like,
is everything in this field
of nuclear science engineering
computational in nature?
Because so far, we've
pretty much just
thrown theory and
simulations at you,
we haven't done any experiments.
So who shares this
concern or wonder?
So 1, 2, 3, 4--
OK, 5, yeah.
So getting towards
roughly half of you.
So I can confidently
answer, no, this is not
a purely computational field.
We just had to get you just
enough science and physics
so that you'd be able to
understand some of the lab
activities that we've got in
store for you, one of whom,
Mike Ames here from
the Nuclear Reactor Lab
is going to be helping
you with-- actually, two
of them he'll be helping with.
MICHAEL AMES: Two?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
Well--
MICHAEL AMES: --your bananas.
MICHAEL SHORT: The
bananas and the thing
that we dreamed up today, so--
MICHAEL AMES: This morning?
OK.
So you want an intro those--
MICHAEL SHORT: Sure.
MICHAEL AMES: --and
I'll, I don't know--
MICHAEL SHORT: Fill
in what I get wrong.
Also, Mike's going
to talk about what
we're going to do together,
which is called NAA,
or Nuclear Activation Analysis.
There are many, many
ways of measuring
what sort of impurities
may exist in materials,
and this is among
the most sensitive.
We happen to have
a nuclear reactor.
So what we will
be doing, what I'm
going to ask each of you guys
to do for a special assignment
that not graded, except you'll
need it for the problem set,
so it kind of is, is
I want each of you
to bring something into me
that weighs about 50 milligrams
in one piece, fits in
here, is not fissionable--
so if you have uranium at home,
I shouldn't know about it.
And we also ask that
you don't bring anything
in that is too salty, because
sodium activates like crazy.
And each of you, using your
knowledge of radioactive decay
that we learned Tuesday
and today, and the Bateman
equations in serious
radioactive decay next Tuesday
and Thursday are going to
calculate what impurities
exist in your sample.
What is your sample?
It's--
MICHAEL AMES: You're
not going to be
able to do the calculations.
MICHAEL SHORT: We're going
to make some estimates of--
MICHAEL AMES: Oh, OK.
MICHAEL SHORT: The isotopes
that you'll let us see.
The shorts, yeah.
I know we're not going to
get every impurity, right?
MICHAEL AMES: Well,
we're not going to able
to run it next week.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yes, but I will
want your materials next week.
OK.
So by Tuesday, I'd
like each of you
to come bring something
in for what you'd
like to know the elemental
composition consisting
of the following elements.
Let's see.
Problem sets, I think
I've got it right up here.
Let me just clone the screen.
So you can see what
we can look for.
So this is provided
to me by Mike.
We're going to do what's called
a short nuclear activation
analysis run looking for any of
the elements up on this list.
Shorts 1 with extremely short
half-lives, and shorts 2
with elements in the
half-lives of hours.
And Mike, I had a question
for you now that we're live.
Can we count arsenic
in that list?
Because it's
24-point-something hours.
MICHAEL AMES: Yeah,
we could do arsenic.
MICHAEL SHORT: OK.
MICHAEL AMES: It's not
a great shorts element.
You'd probably have
to have something
with a bunch of arsenic in it.
MICHAEL SHORT: So
if any of you guys
have some food that
you bought online
and you don't know what sort
of contaminants there are,
or if you've got a
piece of your fingernail
and want to see if you
are what you eat, or--
MICHAEL AMES: After
telling you why fingernails
would be a great
sample, we might
run afoul of the human
subjects in research issue
with fingernails.
MICHAEL SHORT: What
about dog fingernails?
MICHAEL AMES:
--believe it or don't.
Ah, yes, your dogs
are probably not--
MICHAEL SHORT: OK.
So clip your pets'
claws if you want
to see if they
are what they eat,
or don't tell me what nail the
thing came from, or get a--
slice up a piece of a peanut or
whatever your favorite food is.
Or if you want to see if
there are any metal dyes used
in your clothing, cut out a
little 50 milligram square,
it'll be like a fashion
statement and an experiment
at the same time, right?
So we ask that it's
about 50 milligrams,
it's gotta fit in here, it's
gotta be not that salty and not
fissionable, and we're going to
pack a couple of these in one
of these rabbits, these
polyethylene rabbits.
We call it those, one,
because everything in nuclear
is named after animals and farm
implements for some reason.
Did I go over that with you
guys the first day of class?
Barns, shakes, pigs, rabbits?
OK.
So a rabbit is a little capsule.
Do you pop open or
you screw it open?
Oh yeah, there's like a
square nut at the top.
Just a little capsule that
goes through a pneumatic tube,
kind of like the
old bank machines,
and it'll go firing into the
reactor, sit there for a while,
and get pneumatically
sucked back out so that we
can calculate the activation and
decay of the isotopes within.
And a pig is just a
big heavy thing of lead
where you keep pieces
of things that you
irradiated for shielding.
So if you notice the sort
of methodology theme here,
farms, pigs, rabbits,
barns, shakes.
Anyone else you know any
other farmy nuclear units?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Or
farmy anythings?
AUDIENCE: They follow
the [INAUDIBLE] detectors
toads and bullfrogs.
MICHAEL SHORT: So the
detectors in [? nif ?]
are called toads and bullfrogs.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because
the people who made
the acronym
[? like making their ?]
acronyms, and [INAUDIBLE]
bullfrog was not [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHAEL SHORT: So actually
bullfrog stands for something.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHORT:
That's pretty cool.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
acronyms are [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
acronym for acronym.
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh yes,
the acronym for acronym.
As well as what I study,
which is CRUD or Chock River
Unidentified Deposits.
It's the gunk that
builds up on fuel rods.
Well, I talked to a
fellow from Chock River
who took extreme offense
to this detriment
to nuclear power
plants being attributed
to his fine laboratory.
MICHAEL AMES: Oh, I thought
it was chromium-rich.
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh,
see, that would work,
but they're not
actually chromium-rich.
Yeah.
Cool.
So Mike, do you want
to say anything else?
MICHAEL AMES: Yeah.
I think I want to say-- so yeah.
So--
MICHAEL SHORT: You want to
introduce yourself, too?
MICHAEL AMES: Oh yes, sorry.
I'm Mike Ames.
I work over at the
Nuclear Reactor Lab mostly
doing nuclear experiments, but
I also run the NAA lab there.
And I've been doing
it for a while.
So the idea-- the reason
we've got these guys,
it'll irradiate the
samples in this.
The easiest thing for
me to do without losing
any of your samples is
[INAUDIBLE] [? there, ?]
something gets radiated in
this, I slip the top off,
and you probably can't see that,
but it's for a little poly bag.
I'll dump your sample
into the poly bag.
So it's something that's like
one piece that works the best.
What I usually tell
people, it's something
that you could
pick up reasonably
easily with a pair of tweezers.
That way if they drop
it, I can actually
pick it up with tweeers.
But that kind of
gives you a good size.
No-- nothing to powdery,
because the powder
is going to spread around
and then get contaminations.
Yeah, and that list there, I
guess you said you posted it.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
The list has posted
on the Stellar site.
MICHAEL AMES: Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, we'll see mostly
these light elements,
the guys with the astericies.
I don't see that well.
Yeah, gallium I'm probably
not going to see that.
So--
MICHAEL SHORT: Interesting,
we found gallium
in your dog claws or something.
MICHAEL AMES: Yeah, magnesium,
aluminum, titanium, vanadium,
those are easy.
Sodium, chloride, and
potassium are easy.
The manganese will
come out nicely.
Some of the elements of--
generally more interest
down-- further down--
MICHAEL SHORT: Even further--
MICHAEL AMES: --chromium,
those have longer half-lives,
so I'm going to see those.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
MICHAEL AMES: Probably do like
a five or 10-minute irradiation,
let it decay for a little
while, and then we'll
do a couple of counts.
Have you ever get
over to the reactor?
MICHAEL SHORT: We will
be there a fair bit.
MICHAEL AMES: OK, you guys are
going to be there next week.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
So what do you
usually use NAA for?
MICHAEL AMES: NAA,
well, the thing
we've been using it for lately
a lot is anything that's
going to go in the
core of the reactor,
we want to analyze to see if
there's any surprise elements--
to see how much cobalt
is in a piece of steel
that we're going to
put in because people
don't usually
measure the cobalt,
but it activates really well.
And so that causes
problems later
on when we have to
take some compartments
for cobalt-60 or half
the M that shows up
and things that you
don't expect it.
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hmm.
MICHAEL AMES: My past
in doing NAA was all
environmental samples.
So we did a lot
of trace element,
heavy metal chemistry on
atmospheric particulates,
rain water, ice cores, lake
sediments, crude oil, coal,
fly ash.
And so we would measure
that whole stack
of elements and those guys
for environmental studies.
MICHAEL SHORT: Cool.
MICHAEL AMES: That
was my time doing NAA.
I don't know, I
think that's enough.
You want me back here
next Tuesday or Thursday--
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah, to
explain a little bit more
of the specifics of the process.
MICHAEL AMES: --give you
the five, 10 minutes.
And if you guys could--
I mean, are you guys can
be able to come to the lab
when we do the shorts?
MICHAEL SHORT: Depends
on when you do them.
If it's early
November, then yes.
MICHAEL AMES: Yeah, OK.
So when I do shorts, I put two
samples in one of these guys,
they'll shlink into
the reactor and out.
MICHAEL SHORT: Which
you guys should see.
It's pretty cool.
MICHAEL AMES: Yeah, you
can watch that part.
And then I run it
down the hallway
and throw each
sample on a detector.
And while those samples are
counting, I run another rabbit.
So it's kind of an all-day thing
running up and down the hall
every half hour.
So you could almost come
anytime during the day
while I'm running these and get
one full round in half an hour.
MICHAEL SHORT: Cool.
MICHAEL AMES: I think
that's the whole story.
You can hang on to
that if you want.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
Thanks, Mike.
So you heard the charge.
Bring me your dog claws, your
eyebrows, your skin flakes,
your scabs, your--
MICHAEL AMES: Oh yeah, can we--
MICHAEL SHORT: --food pieces--
MICHAEL AMES: --from hair?
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh
Yeah, so no hair.
MICHAEL AMES: We used to do
a bunch of hair analysis.
Hair is a pain in
the neck because it--
MICHAEL SHORT: Staticky?
MICHAEL AMES:
--clings to everything
and it gets stuck to parts.
Yeah, we did some hair
analysis for the superfund site
in Woburn, and it
was a big success,
but it was not pleasant
to do the work.
MICHAEL SHORT: So don't
bring us your hair,
but bring us your skin flakes,
your scabs, your dog claws,
your food scraps, your--
MICHAEL AMES: No skin flakes.
MICHAEL SHORT: Just
don't tell him.
MICHAEL AMES: Stuff
that you can--
like I said, something
that's like one good piece
that you can pick it up--
MICHAEL SHORT:
Yeah, get creative.
MICHAEL AMES: --be great.
MICHAEL SHORT: It doesn't have
to be something that I said.
As long as it's not
fissionable or salty.
MICHAEL AMES: And we
might veto samples--
I do need to know what they
are roughly before we throw it
in the reactor, and we might
end up vetoing some samples.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
So let's figure
it out by Tuesday.
That way if we have to veto,
we have a while for you guys
to find another sample.
MICHAEL AMES: Or-- yeah.
I don't know if I'll be able
to run a sample from everybody.
MICHAEL SHORT: We'll see.
MICHAEL AMES: We'll see.
MICHAEL SHORT: We'll
see what we can do.
MICHAEL AMES: Anyway, I'll
see you all next week.
MICHAEL SHORT: Thanks, Mike.
So yeah, so Mike's
going to be helping
us do some nuclear activation
analysis, and in addition,
next week we're
going to be counting
our big bag of burnt bananas,
because now that you're
learning about radioactivity,
and this-- when
we go over activity
and series decay,
you'll have enough
of the science
to understand to
calculate how to what
is the radioactivity
of one banana.
And to do so, we
need like 500 bananas
to get enough statistics.
So we'll be going to
the reactor for that.
We've also set it up so
that next week and the week
afterwards you guys are going
to be manipulating the power
levels of the reactor.
So you'll actually get to
sit in the control seat,
raise and lower
the control rods,
and watch the power
of the reactor change
in ways you probably
won't expect unless you're
getting operator training.
And all of that stuff is
going to be used in the lab
components of the problem sets.
So you guys might
have noticed there
was some spinthariscope
scope thing on problem set 3.
Radiation protection
did not want
me taking smoke detectors apart
and giving them all to you
because that's distributing
open radiation sources
and I probably
shouldn't do that,
but we've got
plenty of lab stuff
for you to do to
see what is actually
hands-on in this field.
And if you do want to know
what else is hands-on,
I have an experimental
group and you're always
welcome to come see
what we do at the lab.
There usually isn't an
explosion happening,
but there's usually
something that 1,000 to 1500
Celsius temperature,
blue uranium fluoride
salts, nanonewton forces,
extreme pressures, or what
have you, we do a lot of it.
So I wanted to give a quick
review of where we were
in radioactive decay last time.
I think we left off somewhere
around "Particle Physics
Telescope Explodes" was my
favorite BBC headline ever
when we were talking
about-- we've already
gone over alpha decay,
we've gone over beta decay,
we started talking
about positron decay
and the neutrinos
that come out of that,
and this Kamiokande
detector that
is set up with lots of
expensive phototubes
to detect the
cones of light left
as neutrinos pass faster than
the speed of light in water
through water.
And then there is my
favorite headline.
I believe we made it up to the
end of positron annihilation
spectroscopy or ways
that you can actually
use positron emission
to look at the number
and types of atomic defects
in crystalline materials.
And yep, that's where we
left off, interested in PAS?
Lots of papers to check out.
In the meantime,
let's look at one
of the competing mechanisms
for positron emission, which
is electron capture.
In this case-- so
I will warn you,
it's sometimes a little
easy to get mixed up
between electron capture,
internal conversion,
isometric transition, so I've
left these slides on here,
and I also took pictures
of the board from last time
and posted them on
the Stellar site.
So all the blackboards
where we filled the boards,
there's pictures of those.
And I'm going to
keep doing that.
So if you've learned better just
by looking and listening rather
than writing
everything, feel free.
If you want to write stuff
down, also feel free.
So an electron capture,
another way of,
well, destroying positive
charge would be for the nucleus
to capture an electron.
So either it can
emit a positron,
giving away some
positive charge,
or it can capture an
electron, destroying
one of the positive charges.
And in each case here, we've got
a proton that becomes a neutron
and something.
I'm won't be specific as to
which one because positron
and electron capture, well,
two different but similar kind
of decaying mechanisms.
And then what you
get is this hole
where the electron used to be.
And that's not a very
stable configuration
for an atom to have, let's say,
one fewer electron then protons
and especially to have a
hole in the inner shell.
So you get this cascade from
straight-up from high school
chemistry of electrons falling
from one shell to the next
and giving off
characteristic X-rays--
that's me that cross
that out there--
because you will
find misinformation
all over the place
online, and someone
might make a great
figure and mislabel
an electron-emitted photon
as a gamma ray, and remember,
we said gammas come
from the nucleus,
otherwise they're
indistinguishable photons.
And so in electron
capture, you don't
need much of an
energy difference
between the parents
and the daughters,
unlike positron decay where
for positron decay to happen,
you have to have
Q at least equal
to 1.022 MeV, which is the
same as 2 times the rest
mass of the electron.
For electron capture, you don't.
This can happen at
just about any energy.
As long as you can overcome
just the binding energy
of the electron,
which is negligible
compared to these sort
of nuclear energy levels.
And so this is the Q equation.
Keep in mind, these deltas
here are excess masses.
So I'll put this up
again, the excess mass
is the real mass minus
the terrible approximation
of a nucleide's mass.
And this way, excess mass and
real mass are directly related,
so you could plug
in masses here,
you could plug in
binding energies
by making everything with
a minus sign, and so on.
I think I've repeated myself
enough for the Q equation
stuff, would you guys agree?
Yeah, OK.
And so these are actually
two competing mechanisms.
So shown here is the
decay of sodium-22
which we don't want to happen in
our nuclear activation analysis
because it gets pretty toasty.
It can either proceed--
there's a kind of hidden
part of the diagram
that I drew in to make
a little more sense.
You start off with the nucleus
at 2.8 MeV above the neon
nucleus' energy level.
You need 1.022 MeV to create
the positron-electron pair,
at which point you can emit the
positron with a certain energy.
You're left in an excited
state, and the next thing
we'll go over is gamma decay
or Isometric Transitions or IT.
That's the next method of
decay we'll talk about.
Or the nucleus can just
capture an electron,
getting to that
same energy level
and emitting the same gamma ray.
So these are two competing
mechanisms of decay.
And then you might
ask, well, when
is one going to happen
and not the other?
Well chances are,
the lower energy
that transition is, the
more likely electron
capture is going to happen.
So when you look at
these energy diagrams,
you can see that as the
transitions get bigger,
the probability of positron
decay goes up and up and up.
So you need 1.022 MeV to make
the positron an electron,
but the probability of positron
decay very close to this
is fairly low.
Possible, but unlikely.
Is everyone clear on these
two competing mechanisms?
So one way of reducing
the number of protons
is emit a positron, another
is gobble up an electron.
In the end, they make the
same daughter products,
but they go by
different mechanisms.
And they give off
different bits of radiation
which we can actually
sense and measure.
Cool.
So on to gamma decay or
isometric transition.
These range from
the dead simple,
like technetium-99
metastable giving off
a characteristic 140 keV
gamma ray for technetium,
that's the medical
imaging procedure
we've talked a lot about.
To the ridiculously
complex, like americium-241,
which has a lot, a lot, a lot
of different nuclear energy
states, all of which
release anywhere between 1
and a lot of gamma rays.
And this is what's referred
to as isometric transition.
So we'll say gamma or
isometric transition
is like the same thing, they're
just different words for it.
These are called isomers.
They've got the same number
of protons and neutrons,
so it's the same nuclide,
but at an excited state.
And we call it gamma
decay because we
emit gamma rays or photons.
I think this one is the
easiest one to understand,
because the reaction
goes something like--
let's say we have
a parent nucleus
with Z protons and A neutrons.
Nothing happens.
It's about the easiest
nuclear reaction there is.
Except you do give
off a gamma ray.
And we'll usually put
a star or something
to denote an excited state.
So when you see a star
in the reading over there
on a nuclide where
the charge would be,
that's an excited energy
state that will likely
decay by IT or gamma decay.
There is also a
competing mechanism
for isometric transition
or gamma decay,
and that's what's called
internal conversion.
In this case you
can kind of think
of it-- this isn't the
correct physical explanation,
but it's a perfectly
good mental model,
that the gamma ray
would either just
be emitted from the nucleus, at
which point you would see it,
and the energy of the gamma
is the same as that Q,
or it kind of hits an
electron on its way out,
ejecting that electron.
So instead of
finding a gamma ray,
you may just get an electron
emitted at an energy very, very
close to that gamma ray.
The difference between the gamma
ray energy and the electron
energy is its binding energy.
Because if a gamma hits an
electron on the way out,
it has to overcome the binding
energy of that electron,
at which point the
rest of the energy
is just its kinetic energy.
So again, I don't think that's
the precise physical mechanism,
but it's a perfectly good mental
model to remember what this is.
A gamma can either
just get out on its own
or it can hit an
electron on its way out.
If you hit the electron
on your way out,
just like in electron
capture, then
you get a larger shell electron
falling down to the inner shell
emitting an X-ray
just like before.
And then there's
one other process
I want you guys to be aware of.
Has anyone here ever heard
of Auger electron emission?
Er, yeah.
So in this case, instead
of sending out an X-ray,
you can think of it like
the X-ray kind of hits
the-- another electron
on its way out.
That's not the actual
process that happens,
but let's just think
of it like that.
And then that electron
is ejected usually
from a much outer shell.
And we can actually use
these Auger electrons
because they have specific
but very low binding
energies to do
imaging and elemental
analysis of materials.
So this is another one
of those things where
the stuff you're learning today
is used in an Auger electron
microscope up and Building
13 to do combined imaging
and elemental
analysis of materials.
I want to skip back a
sec, because let's say
we have this decay diagram
right here, a pretty simple one.
Cesium-137, that
isotope that everyone
was worried about from the
release from Fukushima.
Can either proceed
by just beta decay,
or beta decay followed by
an isometric transition.
And shown here is a spectrum
of all the different electron
energies that you'll get out.
If you remember from last
time when we talked about,
let's see, the energy of a beta
particle emitted versus let's
say the number of those
particles emitted,
if this is the Q value
for that reaction,
you don't always get
a beta particle out
at the Q value-- in
fact, you never do.
It looks something
like this, where
they'll be some,
let's say, average
or some most likely beta energy,
which is about one-third Q.
Depends on the reaction, but
that's a good rule of thumb.
So if you've got a
1.174 MeV beta particle,
you're going to see a spectrum
of electron energies ranging
from 0 to 1.174.
And you've got this
other beta transition
possible at about
half an MeV, so you're
going to see that same
spectrum right there.
And then there's these two,
what's called the conversion
electrons.
That's evidence of the competing
process with gamma decay.
Which is to say that this gamma
decay can either just get out,
at which point you see a
gamma ray of that energy,
or that gamma hits an
electron on its way
out, knocking those
electrons out.
Does anyone know here what it
means by K-shell or L-shell?
If you do, just shout it out.
So that there depends on the--
oh, that's correct.
It's the energy level.
So let's say we'll draw kind
of a bore model of a nucleus,
we'll call it N. And let's
give it three electron energy
levels.
And let's say there's a couple
electrons in the first shell
and some electrons
in the outer shells.
And let's say this electron
was struck on its way
out by a gamma ray.
So it's gone.
At this point, you might
have an electron fall
from let's call this
level 2 to level 1.
And so this 2-to-1 transition
is called the K-transition.
Don't ask me why the letters
are the way they are.
I probably have read it
and have forgotten it
because it wasn't
that intuitive,
but this is referred
to as a K-transition.
So you may have what's
called the K-alpha
or a K-beta line,
that depends on
if you have an even
higher energy shell,
but whatever this letter is, it
tells you what an energy level
the electron is going to.
So the K lines would be here.
The L-line-- yeah, I'm sorry.
Let me back up and
say that again.
So the idea here is
that if this the--
but let's see.
Which one is this?
0.662.
So if the gamma ray
is at 0.662 MeV, which
would be about there, notice
that these K-shell and L-shell
lines aren't quite 0.662.
That's because they have to
overcome the binding energy
of the electron to get out.
So to jump back to this
diagram right here,
the gamma ray loses a
little bit of energy
in freeing the electron,
the rest of which
can become kinetic
energy, which is
why you can see that
the electron, let's say,
was ejected from
the K-shell here.
And-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So internal
conversion is the actual process
of-- when we figure out
the process of a gamma ray
hitting the electron?
MICHAEL SHORT: I will say
that internal conversion,
you can imagine a mental
model of the gamma ray
hits an electron on its way out.
AUDIENCE: But it's not
the actual-- that's
not physically happening?
MICHAEL SHORT: Physically
it's more complicated.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Looks
like a [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
Yep.
So if you want remember
like what's what,
I would say, just remember
this diagram right here.
Yeah, Kristen?
AUDIENCE: You get a gamma
ray and an electron or just
the one--
MICHAEL SHORT: Just
the-- you get just
the electron, good question.
Is the gamma ray is
effectively absorbed
in freeing the electron
from its bound shell
and then imparting
kinetic energy.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Is the
Auger emission is
when another electron
hops down an energy level
and that [INAUDIBLE] electron?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
So that's correct.
So I'll spend the
next couple of slides
going over what Auger
electron emission is,
but not till we finish the
easier stuff, because Auger
is a little complicated.
Did I see another
question out here?
Cool.
So again, all the competing
methods for gamma decay,
one, the gamma can just
get out; two, the gamma
can knock out an
electron from, let's say,
the K-shell or the L-shell or
the M-shell and so on and so on
depending on what
elements you have.
So I'll just label these.
Like this would be
like the K-shell,
this would be the L-shell,
this would be the M-shell.
Now I want you to
notice something, too.
The K-shell electron ejected
from the innermost electron
is slightly lower than
the L-shell electron.
Why do you guys think that is?
Let's look at the energetics
for this process, right?
The electron energy level is
whatever the gamma ray level
is minus the binding energy.
Which of these two electrons,
the K-shell or the L-shell,
do you think is going to
be more tightly-bound?
The K-shell.
The innermost electron
is more bound,
so it takes away more
energy from that gamma ray.
Let's say this is the gamma.
It takes more energy to eject
an electron from the K-shell
than the L-shell.
Or in other words, the
gamma loses less energy
ejecting a less-bound electron.
So that's why you see these.
If there were an
M-shell, there--
I don't know what element
this was drawn for,
but let's say-- oh, for cesium.
So there probably is an M-shell.
It's just that as you get
down in energy levels,
the probability of
finding an electron
from these outer and
outer energy levels
gets way and way less likely.
So you'll usually just see
a K or an L-shell electron.
And if I asked you to draw
one of these on a problems
set or an exam, just drawing
the K and the L-shells
is perfectly sufficient.
Because that way at least
you'll know that there's
a couple of possibilities.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What are the two
curves on the right graph
there?
MICHAEL SHORT: On this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHORT: So
these two curves
represent the probability of
finding an electron emitted
at that energy.
So this curve right
here where you
get a maximum beta energy of 512
keV comes from that beta decay.
And the maximum for the 1.174
comes from this beta decay.
So the total curve
would be the sum
of each of these four things.
If I just said draw
the total probability
of detecting an electron
at that temperature,
you just add those up.
I saw two other questions
or were they the same thing?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was going to ask
what the [? lower ?]
[INAUDIBLE],,
but his question made me think.
So is it kind of like the
area under both those curves
sums to 1?
Because the probability given
that like 0.512 max is 95% of--
MICHAEL SHORT: Ah.
So the question was is the area
under each of these curves 1?
Not with this scale.
Here we're just showing a
relative number of electrons.
So if you want to find
what's the total probability
that cesium will emit an
electron of each energy,
if you integrate under
all of these curves,
that will sum to 1.
If you're looking at
just one of these decays
and you're saying, if
cesium undergoes this decay,
what's the probability of
each of these energy levels?
Then you only integrate
under the relevant curve.
What's more practical
is usually what's
the probability of
finding any electron
at any energy from cesium?
Then you take into account
all the possible decays,
draw all the curves
independently, add them up,
and you get the
total probability
function whose area will be 1?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So maybe you could
say that all L-shell electrons
would be ejected if [INAUDIBLE]
in the K-shell due to the fact
that it's less tightly-bound?
MICHAEL SHORT: Wait, can
you say the last part again?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't we say
the L-shell electron will
be ejected if [INAUDIBLE] energy
in the K-shell due to the fact
that it's not as tightly-bound?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's correct.
So the L-shell electron
in the second shell
is less tightly-bound than
the first one, which is why
it's ejected with more energy.
It doesn't take as much of the
gamma's energy to get it out.
If you were to get, let's say,
the outermost electron ejected,
which happens and Auger,
which we'll go over next,
it can take up anywhere
from 1 to 7 eV.
Really, really low energy.
That's what we call the work
function or the energy required
to make the outermost
electron out.
So any other questions on this
before I go Auger and show you
that process?
Cool.
So then let's get into what
is Auger electron emission?
It's exactly-- Luke,
is that what you said?
Were you asking about it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah So it's
exactly like what Luke said.
Normally if you have a hole
in a lower-level energy shell,
an electron from a higher shell
will fall down to fill it,
emitting an X-ray.
A competing process for
this is another electron
from a very similar energy
shell will get ejected instead.
The mental model for
this, which again, is not
the true physical picture but
it's perfectly fine to think
of it like this, the X-ray hits
another electron on its way
out.
And you can look at the
energetics accordingly.
Where for Auger emission,
let's say the kinetic energy
the Auger electron
is the difference
in the final and initial
electron energy states
minus the binding energy
of the Auger electron,
which will usually be very
low, because the Auger
electron that's
emitted is usually one
of the outer shell electrons.
So to help make this a
little more concrete,
I wanted to show--
I will do a little calculation
example-- it's just addition,
so it's not that hard.
So let's say we were measuring--
I don't even know what this is.
And we started to see some
characteristic Auger electrons
for copper, platinum,
carbon, and oxygen.
And the question is, why
do we see oxygen coming out
right there at about 501 eV?
Very, very low energy
compared to what
we've been talking about.
We can actually look at the
binding energies of some
of the different electrons
in oxygen. Luckily
there aren't that many
electrons in oxygen. The first--
the only-- well, the
only K electrons,
let's say, have a
binding energy of 532 eV,
the L1 is 24, and then
the L3's something else,
and one of the other
p orbitals is 7 eV.
And so the formula
is pretty simple.
It's just 532 minus 24--
that's the difference between
the final and initial energy
levels--
minus the seven to free
that outer electron--
comes to 501 eV, which
is exactly where you
see the Auger line for oxygen.
So when I ask you what are all
the possible things that you
could see during the decay
of something, something,
something, if I were
to show you this curve
and ask what's missing,
what would you do?
Where would you draw the
Auger electrons on this curve?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Like almost
on the vertical axis
because it's [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
500 eV would be like, I
don't know, one pixel away
on this graph.
But if you want a complete
answer to this question,
you've got to take into account
all the possible beta energies
for all the possible
beta decay mechanisms;
all of the possible conversion
electrons for whatever gamma
come out-- in this case,
there's only one gamma;
and Auger electrons which could
compete with X-ray emission.
So everyone clear on that?
Yeah?
So the question is if
you eject an electron
from one of the inner
shells, does that eventually
create an Auger electron, right?
It can.
These are competing processes.
So to the X-ray can just
escape during that transition,
or we'll assume that it hits
another electron on its way
out and emits an Auger electron.
So these are also
competing processes.
So you'll see one or
the other-- in reality,
you'll see a lot of both
with different probabilities.
Because you're usually
not looking at one atom,
it's usually looking at a lot.
Cool.
Any other questions on IT
as an isomeric transition
or internal conversion or
Auger, what this is all about?
Cool.
Wanted to give
you one note, too.
That these Auger
electrons are really,
really low energy, which means
the only ones that get out
of the material are in
the top, like, tens or so
nanometers of the material.
So it's a very
surface-sensitive technique.
So if you want to do a
really detailed surface
analysis or profiling, you
can scan an electron beam
across the sample and then
collect the Auger electrons
that come out--
skipping ahead to
our calculation--
and get an elemental
profile that'll
tell you how much
of each element
is where depending on how
many of its Auger electrons
you can count.
And it's pretty-- it's
a pretty cool technique.
There are just machines
that do this now.
Any interest in seeing
one of these at the Center
for Materials Science
and Engineering,
because we could try
to arrange that, too?
Cool, OK.
I'll see what I can do.
That'll be fun.
And the last decay that
we haven't talked about
and did not show up in
our generalized decay
diagram from last time.
We did talk about
neutron decay, there's
one other one that probably
wouldn't fit on this diagram.
Does anyone know what it is?
Spontaneous fission.
So this can happen--
that's right.
This happens with
very heavy elements.
Then usually the heavier
it is, the less stable
it is, the higher
probability this
is at which the nucleus can once
in a while, it-- nuclei just
explode sometimes.
Giving off two fission products,
any number of neutrons--
usually between
1 and 3, a couple
of gamma rays, some
anti-neutrinos,
and a whole bunch
of other crazies.
And so that, of course,
doesn't fit on the diagram,
but it is another type
of decay that I'll
ask you guys to analyze
on the homework.
And here's a hint-- you
already analyzed part of it
in problems set 1.
I'll ask you to go a little
deeper in problem set 3.
So anyone have a
question for myself?
Cool.
OK.
Bear with me because
I skipped back
to like slide really far away.
Oh cool.
That thing actually works.
Right to the summary.
So in summary, the radioactive
decay processes are more--
I think the energetics
are pretty easy.
The formulas aren't that hard
to remember because most of them
are just parents minus
daughters minus something.
But what I do want
you to remember
is which mechanisms compete
with which other ones and why.
And if I were to tell you,
draw me a spectrum of photons
that you may see from
the decay of caesium-137,
or draw me a spectrum
of electrons,
you'd be able to
draw what that is
so that when you
go do lab number 4
and we count our big
bag of burnt bananas
and you know that there's
potassium-40 in there,
you know what peaks
to start looking for.
Because you're not
just going to see--
let's do a little
flash-forward to detectors now.
And some other stuff that
nuclear engineers actually
do on a daily basis.
Let's say you're counting
the energy of photons
as a function of, let's
say, the number of photons
that you count.
You're never-- you're
almost never just
going to see a lone
potassium-40 peak like that.
It's very, very rare
that you would just
capture the gamma ray as is.
There's going to be
a lot of other things
that will go into it, which
I'm not going to give away yet
because we're going
to go over photon
interactions in
like a week or two,
but you do have to
think about, well, what
other X-rays might you see?
What if the gamma-- what if
this gamma ray hits an electron
on the way out, and then
you end up with some X-rays?
Let's say you might
have some K-level X-rays
and some L-level X-rays
and maybe some Ms?
These could all be
possible as well.
I'll just label
those real quick.
Does anyone know how
to find these energies?
What those X-ray levels are?
Anyone ever heard
of the Lyman series?
The emission lines from ionized
hydrogen or anything like that?
That's kind of the
simpler case of it.
The idea here is if
you want to figure out
what's the wavelength of light
that's going to be emitted,
it'll be that's this thing
called the Rydberg constant,
a more complex formula for which
I have in the notes, times 1
over your final
shell squared minus 1
over your initial shell squared.
So the idea here is that
you can look up these--
this Rydberg constant
for any element
that you have, and
there's actually--
there's what's called
an R infinity constant
and I think you
just multiply by Z--
I forget what power it is, but
I will get it for you next time.
And then it's just a
matter of the squares
between the final and
the initial shell levels
where n can vary from 1
to theoretically infinity.
Realistically I've never heard
of anything beyond a g orbital,
so let's just say it's that.
Or something like that.
I'll leave the infinity there.
That's technically correct.
OK.
And so all you need to
do is either look up
or calculate this
constant for your element,
and then plug-in the
numbers of the shells,
and you know what sort of photon
energy you're going to get out.
And to make that easier
for you, I think now
is a good time to introduce
the NIST X-ray tables.
So I want to make sure
you can see my screen.
And I'm going to
show you something
that's on the Stellar
site which will
help you figure this stuff out.
20.2.0.0.1.
Good, you can see.
Probably will make log in.
And all the way at the bottom
of the material section,
there's the NIST X-ray
Transition Energy Database.
So for example,
you can look at--
I don't know, we were
looking at caesium, right?
Let's find caesium.
And you can start to
look at all transitions--
let's look at the simplest one.
KL1.
An electron going from shell
number 2 to shell number 1.
Get transitions, and you end up
with a table of these energies
in electron volts.
So if I were to
ask you, let's say,
what sort of gamma rays might
you see coming off of caesium,
that would be the most likely
one where you're more likely
to eject an
inner-shell electron,
and it's most likely that a
number 2 shell electron will
fall down to a number 1 or from
the L-shell to the K-shell,
whatever you want
to call it, or the--
some level orbital
to some other--
there seems to me like
eight different letters
that describe the same thing.
I hope you guys get the idea.
If you want to look at all
the possible transitions,
I have to zoom back out again.
Yeah.
Let's just scroll through it.
But what I want you to notice is
that all of the KL transitions
are within like a couple
hundred eV from each other.
So this is like the first
or second or third L-shell
electron falling to the K-level.
So they call it
the KL1, KL2, KL3.
They're all from L-shell.
They all just might be one
of the different electrons
occupying that shell, which is
why they're not that different.
So if I asked you, draw
all of all of the X-rays
and gammas coming
out, I don't want
to see a line for
every single level.
I'm very happy for you just
to say, this line represents
the KL series, this
line represents
the KM series, all the things
from shell 3 to shell 1.
Notice also that
because it's final
minus initial squared,
which I covered up,
falling from an even
further outer shell
to the same inner shell should
give you a higher energy,
which it does, by like 5 keV.
And then the KN levels,
another 500 eV up.
They don't have KO's.
Interesting.
But they have the K-edge.
Anyone know what the K-edge is?
Exactly.
It's level infinity, which
would mean an electron
from somewhere else, right?
So this in effect
is like the energy
it takes to ionize a
K-electron or the X-ray
that you would get from
an electron falling
all the way into the K-shell.
So this is your kind
of level infinity.
Notice, it's not that
different from level 5.
That's why I wrote 6, I erased
it for theoretical correctness,
but in all practicality,
you won't see much else.
Does anyone have a question?
Thought I saw a hand.
OK.
Let's look at the
L-series-- oh yes?
AUDIENCE: Sometimes you
see L-alpha, L-beta.
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is that the same as
the subscript 1, 2, 3, and 4?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah,
that's another--
AUDIENCE: --corresponding--
it's just a notation.
MICHAEL SHORT: Exactly.
Yeah, there's the
L-alphas, the L-betas,
or you may see L-alpha 1
and 2 in L-beta 1 and 2.
So L designates that it's
going to shell level 2.
Alpha or beta is like LM or LN.
Again, I think I've ranted
about notations before.
Physics is notorious,
because whoever--
to describe
something, and it gets
enough people to infect
with the notation
that you decide it sticks.
But the main patterns
to look at, then,
let's say the L1 M whatever.
This is from level 3 to
level 2, and notice how
much lower an energy these are.
And the L-edge.
5 keV compared to like 36 keV.
And all of these sort
of different transitions
you can calculate
with this formula.
And this has just kind of
tabulated this formula for you.
So whatever you're
more comfortable doing
is putting this in Excel, look
it up on NIST, your choice.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If we were to
calculate that by hand--
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: --what would
you use for like NF?
Say, like, 5?
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh, what is
the largest NF, you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What numbers actually
go in NF [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHAEL SHORT: For that I'll put
my practical thing back there.
You'll never see it
much higher than 6
unless you're talking
about actinides
and super heavy elements with
even crazier shell levels.
But you'll put the
integer shell number,
regardless of whether they
call it L or S or whatever.
Just put the number
here, and that
will give you the-- a
pretty good approximation
of the energy transition.
Does anyone remember
this from high school?
I hope they're
teaching this now.
AUDIENCE: We learned
this in [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh,
they did in 5-111?
Oh, that's good to hear.
What about 3-091?
Anyone take that?
No one took 3-091?
Wow, OK.
Usually it's like
half and half or so.
Cool.
And let's see, how
far does it go?
All the way to the L3
N's in the L3 edge.
So that's the biggest
element they have talking
about ridiculous transitions.
Yeah.
So notice also,
as you go up in--
that's number 100.
So this is the
heaviest one they have,
so most likely to have the
largest number of levels.
So here, the KL1
is like 114 keV,
sometimes
indistinguishable from some
of these smaller nuclear
energy level transitions.
So remember I said before,
chemistry and nuclear differ
by about a factor of a million.
Well, not so if you're
talking about weak gammas
versus heavy elements K-shell
transitions or their K-edges.
Let's see, the largest
X-ray you'd expect
would be the K-edge at 142 keV.
And the technetium-99 gamma
ray comes out of 140 keV.
How do you know if it's
a gamma or an X-ray?
You don't.
Unless you have really, really
good energy resolution and you
can tell them apart.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This
formula in this chart
is only for caluclating
energy of X-rays, right?
MICHAEL SHORT: Correct.
This--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for gammas.
MICHAEL SHORT:
Things get quantum.
So the question was, this
formula and this chart,
yes, this is only for
X-rays and electron shells.
There are probably
equivalent calculations
for nuclear energy levels.
I will say that's a 22.02
and far beyond topic.
For the nuclear
energy levels, just
use the decay diagrams
to find those.
Yeah.
The table of nuclides and
all their different diagrams.
Cool.
How far do we go here?
LN-- yep, there's no O's.
So they never talk about
anything beyond shell level 4,
even for fermium.
So ha, I stand corrected.
OK.
Cool.
So what I wanted
to show you quickly
is is that series of
hydrogen emission lines.
So how familiar does
this look to folks?
Where you can have a
transition from level 3
to level 2, level 4 to level
2, and you can actually--
this is a kind of
neat thing to verify.
I don't it as a
problem set question
because it's not
very nuclear, but you
can try this on your own and
verify that you can actually
calculate the expected
wavelength of these photons
coming off of excited hydrogen.
Also notice here,
it goes all the way
out to 9 and out to
infinity, because this
is electronic excitation.
You won't usually get
the ejection of anything
beyond an M or an N electron
even in the largest elements
from, let's say,
from IC-- what is it?
From internal conversion.
But you can
electronically excite
them to whatever energy level
to the point of even ionizing
them.
That's where the
infinity comes in.
Cool.
So it's like two of five of.
So I want to open this up to any
questions about decay before we
move upstairs to talk about
activity, half-life, and series
radioactive decay, which is what
nuclear activation analysis is
all about.
So anything here?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Just making
sure I understand this.
So the H-alpha lines transition
from N equals to 3 to N
equals 2.
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Would you call that--
in our previous notation, would
you call that LM transition?
MICHAEL SHORT: Correct.
In our pre-- in
our other notation,
this would be known
as an LM electron.
And probably L1M1
because there is only one
electron in hydrogen. Yep.
So don't let the
notations trip you up.
As long as you--
I'm sure someone's
got a chart of L
equals 2 equals whatever
other Greek letter
someone has designated it for.
There's just different ways
of saying the same thing.
So as long as you
know the physics,
looking up the notation is
just kind of a little pain.
Any other questions on
radioactive decay or competing
mechanisms?
Cool.
Let's take a 10 minute break.
So I'll see you guys upstairs
in Room 307 in 10 minutes.
There's no projector there, so
we'll do it all on the board.
All right.
So I want to start off the
second half of today's class
by posing and
answering a question.
Who's still mentally having
trouble grasping this idea?
What did I tell you?
Yeah.
So whoever I said it to, I
said at least half the class
is right there with
you, it's true.
So in a sentence, it's this--
Q is the conversion
of mass to energy.
That's all.
And the whole point of
doing this nuclear reaction
energetics to find out if
things are or aren't allowed,
if they're exo or
endothermic is to see
how much mass is
converted to energy
or how much energy has
to be converted to mass.
And if you have
trouble remembering,
just go back to
the equation that I
see on everybody's T-shirts.
And like I said on the
first day of class,
everyone's got it
on their shirts
and no one quite understands it,
not even the nuclear engineers.
Because it's very difficult
mentally to grasp the idea
that energy and matter are
two sides of the same coin
or two different forms
of the same thing.
So for a nuclear reaction
where Q is greater than 0
or exothermic, all that means
is that energy is spontaneously
created from the
destruction of mass.
That's all.
And for a Q less than 0
reaction or endothermic,
when you inject energy into
the system, it is absorbed
and mass is created
straight from this equation.
So does this make more
sense to the folks
that raised their hands,
which is almost everybody?
Q is nothing but
a quantification
of the amount of
matter and energy
that turn from one to the other.
And all the balance
stuff we've been
doing for almost the last month
has been to serve, to quantify,
and to predict it.
So I hope that helps.
I know that MIT students
have this gift for being
able to hide behind
the math, and I
know that's true because
I used to be one myself.
And you could get
through the day
or get through the class getting
the math right without really
understanding the
physics or the mechanism
behind what's going on.
So everything we've done
for the last three weeks
can be summed up
in one sentence--
mass and energy
are the same thing.
We've just had a lot of math
to get there and be able to--
yeah, it still kind
of makes your head
want to explode, right?
If you think about
it, if you make an--
we want to make an
endothermic reaction happen,
you have to put kinetic energy
into one of the particles.
And that system in the
just barely-allowed state,
the nuclei won't really be
moving, or at least the--
yeah.
The nuclei won't really
be moving afterwards,
because you'll have
turned energy into matter.
That kinetic energy is
turned into mass energy.
Just like you can turn potential
into kinetic or thermal
into mechanical or vice versa,
it's other forms of energy.
Kind of mind-blowing.
Well anyway, so now that we
finished radioactive decay,
I want to get into the
concept of activity half-life,
and then we're going
to start but not
finish serial radioactive
creation and destruction.
In your readings, you'll see an
equation that looks something
like this where we're going to
be at the end of the day today.
If you want to show off
how much of some isotope N1
exists as a function
of time, you
may have seen something
that looks like this.
We're going to be
able to understand
how these equations are created,
and because this is MIT,
we're going to take
it further and add
specifically driven
mechanisms, like can you
create an isotope
not just by decay
from one isotope to another,
but by intentionally making it?
Which is exactly how NAA Nuclear
Activation Analysis works.
You fire neutrons
into a material.
They turn into something else
and start decaying in series.
This is what we're going to
be working out the math for,
but I want to make
sure at every step
that we get the physics right.
So first, a very quick
primer on where--
what is activity and where
does half-life come from?
So we define the A, the
activity of a substance
as pretty simple.
It depends on the amount of
the substance that's there,
and it depends on what's
called this decay constant.
So this amount-- let's
just say like atoms.
And this decay constant is
in units of 1 over second.
An activity is in,
let's say, atoms
destroyed or decays per second.
That thing right there is called
the decay constant, lambda.
And if we want to see, let's
say, how much of a substance
is decaying at a certain
time or what's its activity
and get a measure of how quickly
does it take to decay away,
we can start by saying,
well this in effect
is a destruction
rate of isotope N.
So we can make the simplest
of differential equations
and say, the amount of substance
N as a function of time
is just minus its activity,
which equals minus lambda n.
I hope I don't have to explain
how to solve this differential
equation, so I'm going to go
through it pretty quickly.
What's the method
you use for this
to get n as a function of t?
AUDIENCE: 3?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yes.
You're all in 18-03 or
have finished 18-03, right?
This should have been day 1.
So we'll just separate
variables, divide each side
by N, multiply side by dt.
So we get dN over N
equals negative lambda dt.
You can integrate both sides,
and we get the natural log of N
equals minus lambda t plus
some integration constant.
We're going to do a
little bit of trickery,
and to make things in a nice
form that we can deal with,
let's just call this log of N0.
They're just numbers, right?
We haven't defined what this
constant of integration is.
Everyone cool with
us doing that?
So then we can subtract
log of N0 from each side.
And we get log N minus log
of N0 equals minus lambda t.
So this is like saying log of N
over N0 equals minus lambda t.
We'll take either the
power of both sides
and we get N over and not
equals e to the minus lambda t.
And right there you've got your
exponential decay equation.
This is the easy part.
And what this tells you is it
is a larger decay constant.
Well let me ask you
a question, then.
Would a larger decay
constant mean a faster
or a slower decaying isotope?
A larger decay
constant-- correct--
means that you've got more
of these decays happening
per second.
So a larger lambda
means faster decay.
And we also can
define a quantity
called the half-life, which
means N at t 1/2 equals 1/2 N0.
So for that, all you have to
do is plug in t 1/2 for t,
and 1/2 N0 for N0, and you
actually get this relation
where the half-life is just log
of 2 over lambda, better known
as 0.693.
But we'll just leave it
as log of 2 for exactness.
And that's all there really
is for decay in half-life.
So I'll pose another
question to you.
Something with a
larger decay constant,
will it have a larger
or a smaller half-life?
AUDIENCE: Smaller?
MICHAEL SHORT: Smaller, because
they're inversely related.
So I'd say from this
quick derivation,
these are the two
things to note.
Is that something with a larger
decay constant decays faster
and therefore has a
shorter half-life.
So when we were separating
out our isotopes in nuclear
activation analysis into
what Mike called the shorts
and the longs, he was separating
them by half-life to say that--
let's say the same
amount of activation
or the same amount
of creation, the ones
with shorter half-lives will
be hotter, more radioactive,
but for less time.
And so what we're
going to be doing
is what's called short
nuclear activation analysis
because we don't want to
count for like days or weeks
or months.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So is half-life--
is the decay constant just
a property of the given
substance, given element?
MICHAEL SHORT:
The decay constant
is a property of
the given isotope
specific to that type of decay.
So if we were to draw that
generalized radioactivity
diagram--
let's say we have potassium-40,
which can either go by beta
decay to--
what comes in beta--
what comes after--
I think it's calcium-40.
Or it can go by positron or
electron capture to argon-40.
Each of these processes
has a different half-life.
And then in that
chain-- remember,
let's do the
americium-241, and I'm
going to channel
my one-year-old son
in drawing this decay diagram.
It looks something like that
with all sorts of transitions.
I didn't scream like he
usually does, but whatever.
We're on camera.
Each of these decay--
each of these transitions
may also have its own half-life.
So between isometric
transitions,
they're usually very, very
fast, but once in a while
they're not.
Like technetium-99
metastable to technetium-99
has a half-life of
around six days,
which is why it's so useful
as a medical isotope.
So when you see something
marked M for metastable,
all that means is there
is some sort of a gamma,
also known as an IT
transition, with a particularly
long half-life.
Everyone clear on
what all that means?
Cool.
Well, there'll be
some time for it
to sink in because with
these definitions in hand,
I want to pose a
problem to you guys.
Let's say I start off with
some amount of an isotope N1.
And it decays by
some mechanism--
we don't care what--
to isotope N2, and it
decays to some isotope N3
with decay constants
lambda 1 and lambda 2.
This is what we call
serial radioactive decay.
How do we construct
a system of equations
to tell us what is N1 as
a function of time, what
is N2 as a function
of time, and what
is N3 as a function of time?
Where do we begin
in a general sense?
OK, so let's start with N1.
We kind of have an
expression for N1 already,
but let's start out with
a differential equation.
So the form of all
of these equations
for everything serial
radioactive decay and burning
isotopes in a reactor and
creating isotopes in a reactor
is going to take
the following form.
The general equation is simple.
The change equals creation
minus destruction.
Or the simple thing is
let's say the change is
a source minus a sink.
And we'll have to come up for
every one of these isotopes
for a mathematical way to
describe what's the source
and what's the sink.
So if we want to
measure the change in N1
as a function of time, what
are the sources of isotope N1?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Isn't
there no sources?
MICHAEL SHORT: No sources.
We're starting off with
some fixed quantity of N1.
Let's just call it N1,0.
But you're right, there's
no continuous source
of isotope N1.
What about its destruction?
AUDIENCE: Decay to N2?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
Decay to N2.
So we've got the equation
for that right there.
it depends on the decay
constant of number 1
and the amount of number 1.
So what we're doing here--
I love how this course is
timed with 18-03 because you're
learning ordinary differential
equations in 18-03,
and we're going to be solving
everyday ordinary differential
equations for a fair
bit of this course.
So it's one of
those rare times you
get to like learn math and
put it to use at the same time
instead of six years later,
it's just kind of nice.
So that's easy.
Let's go to the more
challenging one.
What is the source
of isotope N2?
AUDIENCE: Decay from N1?
MICHAEL SHORT: Decay from N1.
So how would I
mathematically write that?
AUDIENCE: Just lambda 1 N1.
MICHAEL SHORT: Just lambda 1 N1.
And what is the
destruction of isotope N2?
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Lambda 2 N2?
MICHAEL SHORT:
Takes the same form.
It depends on the decay
concept of isotope 2
and the amount of
isotope 2 that's there.
How about isotope 3?
Where does that come from?
AUDIENCE: Lambda 2 N2?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's it.
The source is lambda 2 N2.
What are the sinks
or the destruction?
AUDIENCE: Nothing.
MICHAEL SHORT: Nothing.
So we have a very simple set
of posed differential equations
to describe the production and
the destruction of these three
isotopes.
So let's imagine now
that N1 was, let's say,
radium, which exists all
throughout the soil and rocks;
N2 is radon, the gas that's
produced from radium decay;
and then N3 could be let's
say one of the stable daughter
products of radon.
So these are the
sorts of calculations
that are done all the
time in real life to see--
if you know how much
radium is in the rock,
how much radon do you
expect to breathe in?
Because at the same time
you're producing radon
from radium decay.
And the radon is
decaying itself.
So you can't just say, oh,
the activity of the radium
equals the amount of
radon because it's
being created and destroyed
all at the same time,
and it depends on how
much there is around.
Same thing with nuclear
activation analysis.
You'll, let's say, you'd
start off with sodium-21,
you can create sodium-22.
Sodium-22 will decay
by positron emission.
What comes before sodium?
Probably neon, I think, 22.
That's my guess.
Yeah.
So if you want to say how
much sodium-22 is there,
well you're both creating it
from sodium-21 from neutron
absorption, and you're
decaying it naturally
by positron emission
among other processes.
We're going to get back into
how do we deal with the neutrons
thing probably on
Tuesday, But for now,
let's work on solving
this system of equations.
So I think N1 is pretty
easy because we already
have the solution for it.
So I'll just write it.
1t.
The harder one is N2.
So what can we start by doing?
We've got an ordinary
differential equation with--
it's just this first order,
but there's two variables.
So how do we deal?
AUDIENCE: Pick another equation?
MICHAEL SHORT: We do it-- well,
we have other equations, so--
actually, we've got this one.
Yes.
Substitute N1 in here so we
get everything in terms of N2
and constants and type.
So we'll rewrite this equation
as dN2/dt, which I'm also just
going to write as N2 prime.
And when you use this a
little bit of notation
that I'll leave up
there on the board
because it's going to be
a lot faster in writing.
Which equals lambda 1 and
10e to the minus lambda
1t minus lambda 2 N2.
Can we separate variables here?
I don't see an easy way.
So, 18-03 experts, how do we
solve this type of first order
differential equation?
And I'll give you--
l won't give you a
hint, I'll give you
a little bit of consolation.
No one from last year
knew how to approach this.
So if you don't know, I
won't be disappointed.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You've got
N2 dot plus lambda 2
N2 equals lambda 1 N1 dot--
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: So you could put--
add lambda 2 N2 to both sides.
MICHAEL SHORT: Add lambda
2 N2 to the both sides.
I think you're on to
what I'm thinking about.
Also, if you can't
read something I write,
please stop me and let me know
and I'll be happy to erase it.
I don't think I've
said that yet,
but it takes a lot
of control for me
to get my handwriting legible
on the board let alone
on a piece of paper.
So if you can't read,
please let me know.
OK.
So now we've got the N2's
separate from the N1's, what
do we do next?
AUDIENCE: --N2 has
the form A times
e to the negative lambda 1t?
MICHAEL SHORT: OK,
let's try this.
Assume N2 has the
form e to the what?
AUDIENCE: Negative lambda 1t?
MICHAEL SHORT:
Negative-- has the form e
to the lambda negative 1t.
AUDIENCE: With that A in front--
MICHAEL SHORT: With an A,
some constant in front.
What makes you say that?
AUDIENCE: Like if you take
the derivative with respect
to time, then the next
term will still have a e
to the negative lambda 1t?
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Cancel all
those out and solve for A.
MICHAEL SHORT: Cool.
So that is one way to do it.
It's going to get a
little messy, though.
There's another
method specifically
for equations of the form.
Let's call it y prime plus--
I'm going to use notation
they may have used in 18-03.
I hear a couple of aha.
Anything look familiar
about this type of equation?
OK, what is it?
AUDIENCE: Not following.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL SHORT:
It's not that hard.
Anyone remember the
word integrating factor?
And it was probably done
horribly and on like six math
boards or whatever.
So I'm going to show you
the simpler way to do this.
The idea here is we want
to multiply everything
by something-- by
some function mu.
Put a mu there, put a mu
there, put a mu there.
I think that's the
notation that's usually
used in differential
equations, such
that this thing right here is
shrinkable through the product
rule.
Or the product rule--
I'm not assuming
everyone remembers--
says that let's say you
have some function a of t,
b of t prime is like a prime
times b plus a times b prime.
So we're kind of getting
around to the method
that Luke was talking
about, but we're
going to do it by a little
bit of a cleaner way.
We multiply every term
by some function mu
such that this part is one
of these perfect product
rules at which point we
can shrink and integrate
the expression.
Without going through
the derivation of how
integrating factors
are done, I'll
just let you know that
this function mu ends up
being e to the integral of p.
Hat is our integrating factor.
So that's the end result
of what was probably
six boards of 18-03.
Am I right or am I mistaken?
Well, things haven't
changed in 15 years.
Cool.
OK, so what is mu
for this equation?
Luckily, p of t
is pretty simple.
Which part of this
equation right here
is our p of t-like term?
AUDIENCE: Lambda 2 N2.
MICHAEL SHORT:
Actually, just lambda 2.
Because we've got our
variable right here
that right there is our p of t.
So we'll just say that mu
equals e to the integral of--
uh, yep-- of lambda 2 dt, which
is just e to the lambda 2t.
That's our integrating
factor right there.
So we'll multiply every
term right here by that.
So we'll say e to the lambda 2t
times and N2 prime plus lambda
2 e to the lambda 2t.
Anyone see what
is going on here?
There's the product
rule thing going on--
times N2 plus e to the
lambda 2t times lambda 1 N10
e to the minus
lambda 1t equals 0.
And we have successfully
created something here
that can be shrunk up
with a product rule.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Should
that be a minus e
to the lambda 2t lambda 1 N1--
when you moved it over?
It's positive--
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh yeah.
There's an equal sign
there, isn't there?
That's what tripped me up.
Thank you.
So there is indeed
a minus sign there
because I skipped the
step putting everything
on one side of the equation.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Could we do this with
variational parameters instead?
MICHAEL SHORT: Where you replace
one variable with-- or replace
a couple of variables
with another one?
AUDIENCE: Well yeah, just
like the homogeneous solution,
and then you'll
find like a factor--
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah.
There are lots of ways
of solving a first order
ODE like this.
Sure.
So this would work with
various parameters.
It would work with what
Luke's talking about.
It works with this one.
This just happened to be
a particularly simple one
because the integrating
factor's so simple.
So let's cram this
up right here.
So this is like
saying N2 times e
to the lambda 2t prime minus--
and we've got two
e to the somethings
that we can combine right here.
So I'll just say lambda
1 and 10e to the lambda
2 minus lambda 1t equals 0.
So now I will put this
term back on the other side
by doing that.
And now we just
integrate both sides.
And we get N2 e to the
lambda 2t equals, let's see.
Becomes lambda 1
N10 over lambda 2
minus lambda 1 e to
the lambda 2 minus
lambda 1t plus some
integration constant C.
And in this case, our
initial condition, well,
how much of isotope
N2 did we start with?
Have we specified that yet?
No?
Let's make it simple.
Let's assume that the initial
amount of isotope N2 equals 0.
We put some isotope
in the reactor
or start it off with some
amount of isotope like radium.
Didn't start off with--
it didn't start off with any
radon, and just kept going.
So then all we have to do is
divide each side by either
the lambda 2t, and
that cancels those,
that cancels that and that, and
we end up with N2 as a function
of time equals lambda 1 N1,0
over lambda 2 minus lambda 1
times e to the minus lambda 1t.
OK.
And we've got an
expression for N2.
How about N3?
Do we even have
to solve this one?
I see a couple of people shaking
their heads no, why is that?
AUDIENCE: Basically you
already solved for N1,
they're just not minus signs.
MICHAEL SHORT: Well, not quite.
Because we-- well yeah, I guess
we've kind of solved it for N1,
but now we take this expression
for N2, stick it in here,
and then solve that,
it's going to get messy.
So I'm going to show you
something mathematically
now that I'll show
you graphically later.
There's a conservation equation
that we're missing here.
If we sum up isotopes
N1, N2, N3, equals what?
Conserving total
number of atoms.
AUDIENCE: N1,0?
MICHAEL SHORT: Exactly.
N1,0.
In this situation
where we started off
with some known quantity
of isotope 1 only,
you can't change the
number of atoms here,
you can only change
the type of atoms.
So we don't have
to solve for E3--
oh sorry, for N3, because N3
is just N1,0 minus N1 minus N2.
And that takes like an extra 10
minutes out of today's lecture.
So later on when we have
a projector on Tuesday,
I will show you these
equations graphed out where
I've-- actually, I'll
share this with you.
Did I tell you guys about the
Desmos graphical calculator?
Or have I shown this to you yet?
Go here for all of
your graphing needs.
It's free, and the
best part that I like
is that anytime you
define some parameter,
it automatically
makes a slider bar
so you can play
with the equations.
And you can just--
say, like, well
what if L1 and L--
lambda 1 and L2 are equal?
What if they were way different?
And it just graphs
the solutions for you.
It's pretty useful.
So I'll show you some
of that on Tuesday
when we actually have a screen.
Let me see what time it is.
Oh sweet, we've
got plenty of time.
So now I want to pose
the following questions
to you guys.
I'm going to erase stuff
from here because we still
have some space.
How do we model nuclear
activation analysis
using this kind of equation?
We'll start off with
the same equation.
So let's say we'll have a minus
lambda 1 N1, we'll have N2,
minus lambda 2 N2
minus something.
N3 equals something-- let's
see, there's a lambda 1 N1,
there's a lambda 2
N2 minus something.
I've left some
trailing minus signs
to indicate that we don't have
complete equations for this
yet.
So for the case of nuclear
activation analysis where
we have some imposed flux--
flux-- of neutrons.
So anyone remember from some
of our previous flash-forwards
how do we turn these into
creation and destruction rates
of these different isotopes?
AUDIENCE: Could you repeat that?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
So let's say we've now
stuck N1 in the reactor.
And we're now using the reactor
to create different isotopes
like N2 and N3, but at the same
time they're in the reactor,
they're getting
cooked as well by some
imposed flux of neutrons.
How do we set up and not
solve the system of equations
to describe this?
AUDIENCE: Are they-- are N2
and N3 both getting like--
MICHAEL SHORT: They're
getting destroyed and whatnot?
AUDIENCE: Are they
just like decaying
or are they also getting like
added stuff from neutrons--
MICHAEL SHORT: Well--
AUDIENCE: Because that
depends on the isotope.
MICHAEL SHORT: That
So let's define
what the system--
this system is.
Let's say we stuck in
some other isotope N0,
and we put it in, and we're
going to have to say it's--
if we have N0 prime, some
minus some creation term.
And in this case, N0 can
absorb a neutron to become N1.
N1 is decaying to N2,
N2 is decaying to N3.
But also, N1 can be
burned by neutrons
N2 can be burned by neutrons and
N3 can be burned by neutrons.
So here I've given you kind
of a simplistic situation that
doesn't usually exist.
Here I've given you
a situation that you
could replicate in the reactor.
How do we model this nuclear
activation analysis process?
Well first of all,
what's the creation
rate of N0, the stuff
we put in the reactor?
Are we creating any?
No?
Luke?
AUDIENCE: It's all going
to be created if N2 absorbs
the neutron and [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHAEL SHORT: It could be.
So if we had this for the
following nuclear reaction,
now it's getting crazy.
We can model that, too.
Let's do it.
OK, I was going to say
no, but let's do it.
We can-- so what I'm
trying to do here is
give you the mathematical
tools to model
any real physical situation.
Usually in this class
like when I took it,
the discussion
stopped here and we
got to start looking at
different graphs of secular
versus transient equilibrium
like in the reading.
But I want you guys to
have the intuition to say,
all right, let's take any
crazy decay diagram, right?
And N3 becomes N1,
let's just go nuts.
How do we set up the
differential equations
for this assuming that
computers can solve them?
In every case-- where's
my long pointer?
Go back to this here.
The change is the creation
minus the destruction.
So what are all the
creation sources
in our new scenario for N0?
Well I pose you a
simpler question.
If there is no isotope
N2, can you create any N0?
No.
Because the only way to
make N0 is to start with N2.
So we know its creation term
is going to have an N2 in it.
What else does it depend on?
AUDIENCE: Cross-section.
MICHAEL SHORT: I heard both
of the pieces of the answer
correct at the same time.
It depends on the
flux of neutrons,
and it depends on
the cross-section.
This macroscopic
cross-section right here.
OK?
Or I'm sorry, no, no.
It depends on the
microscopic cross-section
because we have an amount of N2.
But it does depend on how
many neutrons you throw at it
and what is the probability
of each of those neutrons
make some N0.
So what we've got right
here is a reaction rate.
So who remembers from the
like second or third lecture,
we said a reaction
rate can be expressed
like macroscopic
cross-section times of flux,
which is the same as a
microscopic cross-section times
number density times flux?
But this is better known as
a macroscopic cross-section.
Remember, I kind of showed
this to you very briefly when
we talk about
cross-sections, now
is where we actually use them.
So the cross-section's
like the probability
that a neutron coming in to atom
N is going to react with it.
The macroscopic cross-section
in units of, let's say,
1 over centimeters
is the total--
let's say the total probability
accounting for how many are
there, and the flux is in
neutrons per centimeter
squared per second.
Combine these together,
and you get a reaction rate
in atoms per centimeter
cubed per second,
a volumetric reaction rate.
There we go.
So N1 can be created.
Let's give this cross-section
a designation from N2 to N0.
So let's call it
cross-section 2,0.
How can N not be destroyed?
I'll give you a hint, it looks
very similar to this term.
Anyone want to take a guess?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could it
undergo fission?
MICHAEL SHORT: We
haven't specified that.
I'm going to cut the
craziness at there, I think.
But just look at the
reactions right here.
N0 can absorb a
neutron and become N1.
So how do we
mathematically write that?
AUDIENCE: Minus the
cross-section N--
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
Minus the cross-section of?
AUDIENCE: N1.
MICHAEL SHORT: Let's
say 0 going to 1.
Let's just call it that.
Times the neutron flux.
Times what?
AUDIENCE: Times N0?
MICHAEL SHORT: Times the
amount that's there, N0.
So this is your
destruction term.
Using this pattern, we can
fill in all the remaining terms
for all the remaining isotopes.
So what are the creation
mechanisms for isotope N1?
Well, just follow the arrows.
AUDIENCE: --same term--
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: --on the
first equation for N--
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
There's this one right here.
We can have--
AUDIENCE: --the sign.
MICHAEL SHORT: But flip the
sign because it's creation.
So sigma 0,1 flux N0.
And what else can create
N1 because we're just
going crazy today?
N3 can create N1
because we said so.
But-- yeah, because we said so.
So now we'll say also we'll
have this cross-section for 3
turning into 1
times flux times N3.
Minus the decay of N1 using
our activity expression, minus
what else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
cross-section
of the [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHAEL SHORT: I
heard some-- yep,
that will be the
cross-section of N1.
Let's call it going to
some isotope we don't care
about times the flux times N1.
So as long as you can
draw a like arrow decay
and destruction
production diagram,
we can put this to math.
That's the crazy thing.
Let's finish it up.
How about N2?
We know that N1 can decay to N2.
What are the other
production mechanisms for N2?
Follow the arrows.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: That's it.
Because we're not changing
anything at this point.
What are all the destruction
mechanisms for N2?
AUDIENCE: Decay or [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
It can decay, it can be
absorbed by a neutron
to become something
we don't care about.
Let's see, let's
call it cross-section
2 null times flux times
N2 minus the cross-section
from 2 to 0, just this
term with a minus sign.
How about N3?
What are all the
ways we can make N3?
Could you say it
a little louder?
AUDIENCE: Only from decay.
MICHAEL SHORT: Only from decay.
Again, just see which
arrows are pointing at it.
And what about the
destruction mechanism for N3?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
So there's some probability
it decays, let's say,
cross-section 3 null times
flux times N3 minus this arrow
going back to N1.
Running out of space,
too many units.
From 3 to 1 flux N3.
So the point of accepting the
escalation of this problem
into something crazy
is that it doesn't
matter how crazy it gets.
As long as you have like an
arrow-based diagram or a flow
chart to say which isotopes
become which other isotopes
by which other means, you
can pose and correctly write
the set of equations
that defines them.
This is when I would bring
in MATLAB or Mathematica.
I could make you do
this analytically,
but this isn't a
course 18 class and--
yeah, we don't want to go there.
Cool.
So I think--
I guess it's probably
getting towards 10 of 10 of.
Close enough.
It's like three of 10 of.
So I'd like to open it up to any
questions because we let this--
I let this escalate freely to
prove the point that as long
as you know what
decays into what
or what creates
or destroys what,
you can set up the
equations correctly.
What we'll be doing on
Tuesday is graphing this.
Where we can pose an arbitrarily
complex set of equations
and you can start looking
at, well, the change in one
depends on the
amount of the other,
and you can almost graphically
solve this on paper.
Forget Mathematica in MATLAB.
If you look at last
year's exam, I actually
posed a more
complex set of these
and said draw the solution.
And I'm going to-- we're going
to show you how to do that.
But any question on
how we formed these?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: What is sigma again?
I'm sorry.
MICHAEL SHORT: So we just
said let's say N3 decays
to some isotope we
don't care about.
That's how I initially
had it, and then I
think Luke said, well
can N2 become N0?
And I said, yeah, sure.
So there can be a cross-section
for every type of reaction.
So in reality, you might have
any reaction under the sun,
right?
One isotope could absorb
a neutron and decay
by like any three or
four different mechanisms
into something else.
You may have different
probabilities
for each of these.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do those decay
constants [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: The
only time I'd expect
you to find these decay
constants is if I told you
what these isotopes were.
Those are also listed on
the table of nuclides.
As in they give
you the half-life,
and you know from this
half-life relation
what the decay constant is.
If I didn't tell you
what these isotopes were,
I would just have you
keep these symbols
as lambda 1 and lambda 2.
And I might pose a question
which will solve graphically
on Tuesday, like
let's say, solve
this set of equations
for lambda 2
is much greater than lambda 1.
I don't care what
the numbers are,
let's just look at
that general relation.
And all the graphs for
that sort of situation
will follow the same pattern.
Cool.
Any other questions on how
we constructed this set
of differential equations?
And know that I'll never
ask you to solve them
numerically or analytically.
Yeah.
That's why we have computers
and this is the future.
These I might expect you
to know how to derive,
but this is the
simplest possible case.
All right, if
there's no questions,
then let's take
another 10-minute break
and I'll be here for recitation
to go over whatever problems
you guys would like to do.